do you guys think that the majority of  women want children when they're 18.  i would say  yes because of  the way  society was and how like when we're  younger we're practically  pretending to be mothers with all the  baby dolls we have the kitchen sets and  everything so i would say  it's like  instilled in us like oh you're a woman  you're going to have children you may  not want them at 18 but i think in every  woman's mind do you think it's society  or our or our biology  because when i was growing up  really because when i was growing up i  heard a lot of you can do anything you  want you don't need a man you're a  strong independent woman from the media  hmm  yeah  okay go ahead what do you think  as in at 18 you think in the future i  want to have kids yes